I’d like to dedicate this next song to Carmelo,
who was put to sleep a couple of days ago, because he got too old.
But apparently he was a very nice dog
and he always let the cat sleep in the dog bed.
♫ (Dog panting noise) Heh, heh, heh, heh, heh, heh, heh, heh, heh, heh. ♫
♫ I'm just a'walking my dog, singing my song, strolling along. ♫
♫ Yeah, it's just me and my dog, catching some sun. We can't go wrong. ♫
♫ My life was lonely and blue. ♫
♫ Yeah, I was sad as a sailor, ♫
♫ I was an angry 'un too. ♫
♫ Then there was you -- appeared when I was entangled with youth and fear, ♫
♫ and nerves jingle jangled, vermouth and beer were getting me mangled up. ♫
♫ But then I looked in your eyes ♫
♫ and I was no more a failure. ♫
♫ You looked so wacky and wise. ♫
♫ And I said, "Lord, I'm happy, 'cause I'm just a'walking my dog, ♫
♫ catching some sun. We can't go wrong." ♫
♫ Yeah, it's just me and my dog, singing our song, strolling along. ♫
♫ 'Cause I don't care about your hating and your doubt, ♫
♫ and I don't care what the politicians spout. ♫
♫ If you need a companion, why, just go out to the pound, ♫
♫ and find yourself a hound, and make that doggie proud, ♫
♫ 'cause that's what it's all about. ♫
♫ (Dog panting noise) Heh, heh, heh, heh, heh, heh, heh, heh, heh, heh. ♫
♫ My life was tragic and sad. ♫
♫ I was the archetypal loser. ♫
♫ I was a pageant gone bad. ♫
♫ And then there was you -- on time, and wagging your tail ♫
♫ in the cutest mime that you was in jail. ♫
♫ I said, "Woof, be mine!" and you gave a wail and then ♫
♫ I was no longer alone. ♫
♫ And I was no more a boozer. ♫
♫ We'll make the happiest home. ♫
♫ And I said, "Lord, I'm happy, 'cause I’m just a'walking my dog, ♫
♫ singing my song, strolling along." ♫
♫ Yeah, it's just me and my dog, catching some sun. We can't go wrong, ♫
♫ 'cause I don't care about your hating and your doubt, ♫
♫ and I don’t care what the politicians spout. ♫
♫ If you need a companion, why, just go out to the pound, ♫
♫ and find yourself a hound, and make that doggie proud, ♫
♫ 'cause that's what it's all about, ♫
♫ that's what it's all about, ♫
♫ that's what it's all abou-BOW-WOW-WOW-WOW ♫
♫ that's what it's all about. ♫
♫ (Dog panting noise) Heh, heh, heh, heh, heh. ♫
Good dog!
Thank you.